الولايات المتحده والفلبين اتفاقا يسمح
للجنود الامريكيين باستخدام اربع قواعد
عسكريه اضافيه بموجب اتفاقيه التعاون
الدفاعي لعام 2014 بين البلدين وجاء
الاتفاق مع بدايه زياره وزير الدفاع
الامريكي اليوم لمانيلا حيث اجرى محادثات
مع الرئيس الفلبيني بشان فتح مزيد من
القواعد العسكريه الامريكيه ويربط البلدين
تحالف امني منذ عقود يشمل معاهده للدفاع
المتبادل تسمح للقوات الامريكيه بالانتشار
في خمس قواعد فلبينيه بما فيها تلك
القريبه من مياه متنازع عليها
تحركاته واستون تاتي في سياق مواصله
الولايات المتحده تعزيز قوسها العسكري حول
الصين في شرق اسيا امر ترابيل انه سلوك
بعقليه الحرب البارده تملك الولايات
المتحده العديد من القواعد والمنشات
العسكريه في اليابان منذ الحرب العالميه
الثانيه وعدد قواتها هناك هو الاكبر خارج
الولايات المتحده ويزيد عن خمسين الفا
ورغم مساحتها الصغيره نسبيا تعتبر كوريا
الجنوبيه تعتبر ثالثه اكبر مستضيف للقوات
الامريكيه بعد اليابان والمانيا وفيها
قاعده اكبر قاعده امريكيه من حيث المساحه
وعدد القوات الموجوده فيها ومن خلال
صفقتها لبناء اربع قواعد عسكريه جديده في
الفلبين قامت واشنطن برفع الفجوه في قوس
التحالفات الامريكيه
حول الصين
والفلبين هي الاقرب جغرافيا الى تايوان
بمسافه تقدر بنحو 1200 كم
اندونيسيا التي تضم نحو 17 الف جزيره
بممرات حيويه مهمه تبقى الجائزه الاكبر
وتسعى الولايات المتحده لاستمالتها عسكريا
واقتصاديا في حين تملك الصين فيها
استثمارات اقتصاديه ضخمه